The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: And to
this purpose, we
need to calculate
some thermodynamics.
And we usually do that
in statistical mechanics
by calculating for some kind
of a partition function.
And we saw last
time that it would
be useful to calculate this
grand partition function, which
is the ensemble
where you specify
the temperature, the chemical
potential, and the volume
of the gas.
And in this ensemble,
your task is
to look at within
this box of volume V
the possibility of there
being any number of particles.
So you have to sum over all
possible N particle states.
The contribution of
each N particle states
is exponentially related
to the number of particles
through the chemical potential.
And then given that you are in
a segment that has N particles,
you have to look at all
possible configurations
of those particles
and integrate over
all of those possibilities.
And that amounts to calculating
the partition function.
So for the partition function
of an N particle system,
you have to integrate
over all of the momenta.
Integration over each
component of the momentum
gives you a factor of 1 over
lambda, where lambda again
was related to the mass of
the particle and temperature
through this formula
with h what we
use to make these integrations
over pq combinations
dimensionless.
There are 3N such integrations.
So that's a contribution
from the momenta.
And then we have to
do the integration
over all of the coordinates.
And as long as these
particles are identical,
we decided to divide by
the number of permutations.
Because we cannot
tear them apart.
So having done that, I need to
now integrate over all of the N
particles spanning
a box of size V
so the integration
is within the box.
And when I have
interactions, then I
have to worry about the
Boltzmann weight that
comes from the interaction.
So here I should really
put some kind of e
to the minus beta times
the interaction U.
And what we did was we
said that let's assume
that this interaction comes
from pairs of particles.
And so this U is the sum
over all possible pairs
of particles, which
when exponentiated
will then give you a product
over all possible pairs j, k
and a factor that is related
to the potential interaction
between these.
And we found it useful
to write that factor as 1
plus fjk, where this fjk
stood for e to the minus
beta of V qj minus qk minus 1.
So basically if I
add the 1 to that,
I just get the exponentiated
interaction potential.
And then I have a
forum such as this.
So basically, this
is the quantity
that we wanted to compute.
And so then we said,
well, let's imagine
expanding these factors of
1 plus f1, 2, 1 plus f1, 3,
1 plus f2, 3, all
of these factors,
and organize them according to
the powers of f that they have.
So the leading term would
be taking 1 from everybody.
So that would give
me V to the N, which
would be the 0-th
order partition
function, the
non-interacting system.
And then I would start
to get corrections
where there's order of f
integrated, order of f squared
integrated, all kinds of things.
And that being a somewhat
difficult object to look at,
we said, let's imagine
graphically what we would get.
And the typical contribution
that we would get to this
would involve having to iterate
over all of these N particles.
So we have to somehow imagine
that we have particles 1 to N.
And then for a particular term,
we either pick 1's-- and there
will be some points that are
not connected to any f that is
integrated.
There will be a bunch of
things that will be connected
to things where there
are pair of f's.
There will be things
later on maybe
where there are triplets of
f, and so forth and so on.
And then we said that when
I do the integrations that
correspond to this,
what do I get?
I will get the contribution
that comes from one particle
by itself integrated.
Let's call that b1
to the power of n1.
I will get the contribution
from this pair integrated.
I will get b2 to
the power of n2.
I will get the contributions
from these entities.
And in general, I said,
well, OK, somewhere in this,
I will get bl to
the power of nl.
Now of course, I have
a big constraint here
that is that the
sum over l of lnl
has to be the total
number of points 1 to n.
So however I partition this,
I will have for each graph
that particular
constraint acting.
We said that clearly there's a
lot of graphs and combinations
that give you precisely
this same factor.
But all I had to do was
to sort of rearrange
the numbers and
ordering, et cetera,
and I would get all of this.
So it would be very nice
if I could figure out
what the overall
factor is out here.
So we said that the factor is
something like N factorial.
Because what I can do is I can
permute all of these numbers,
and I would get
exactly the same thing.
But then I have to make sure
that I don't over count.
And not over counting
required me to divide
by the number of
permutations that I
have within each subgroup.
So I have bl to the power of n.
I have l factorial
to the power of nl.
And then I have the change.
Let's say this is
1, 2, this is 3, 4.
I could have called one of
them 3, 4, the other one 1, 2.
So basically I will have nl
factorial from the permutations
within each.
But I would have gotten exactly
the same numerical factor
out front if I had
the same configuration
but I had this diagram.
I would have gotten
exactly the same factor.
I would call the
contribution to this b3.
I didn't say
currently what b3 is.
I would have gotten
exactly the same factor.
So maybe then what I
did was to sort of group
all of those things
that would come
with the same numerical factor
into this [INAUDIBLE] sum
that I call bl.
So I call bl to be the sum
over all l-particle clusters.
And then, of course
here, I have to sum over
all configurations
of nl that are
consistent with this constraint
that I have to put up there.
So the rest of it
then was algebra.
We said that if I
constrain the total number,
it's difficult for me to do.
That's why I didn't go and
calculate the partition
function and switch to the
grand partition function.
Because in the grand
partition, I can essentially
make this N that constrains
the values of these nl's
to be all over the place.
And therefore summing over
things with nl unconstrained
is equivalent to summing over
terms with nl constrained,
and then summing over whatever
the final constraint is.
So once I did that, I was
liberated from this constraint.
I could do the sum for each
value of nl separately.
And the thing nicely
broke up into pieces.
And so then what I
could do is I could
show that each term
in the sum, there
would be a product over
different contributions l.
For each l, I could sum over
nl running from 0 to infinity.
I had the 1 over nl
factorial from out here.
I had an e to the
beta mu divided
by lambda cubed from the
combination of these things
raised to the
power of lnl, which
is how big N would
have been composed.
So I would have here lnl.
And I also had an l factorial
raised to the power of nl.
So I can write things
in this fashion.
So this thing then
became the same thing
as an exponential of a sum over
l running from 1 to infinity.
1 over l factorial,
of if you like
e to the beta mu over lambda
cubed to the power of l 1
over l factorial.
And then I had bl.
So it was this very nice
result somehow summing
over all kinds of things, and
then taking the logarithm.
The logarithm
really depends only
on the contributions
of single clusters.
And again, the
reason it had to be
that way is because
the ultimate thing
that I calculated
in this ensemble
is that the answer
should be e to the beta V
times the pressure.
And so the expression that
we have over here better
have terms which are all
proportional to volume.
Sorry, they're all made
extensive by proportionality
to volume.
And indeed, when I do the
integrations over a single any
cluster, there is one degree
of freedom, if you like,
associated with the center
of mass of the cluster that
can go and explore
the entire volume.
And so all of these things are
in fact in the large end limit
proportional to V and
something that I call bl bar.
So once I divide by this
volume, the final outcome
of my calculation is
that I can calculate
the pressure of
an interacting gas
by summing over a series whose
terms are this e to the beta mu
over lambda cubed raised to
the power of l bl bar divided
by l factorial.
OK, this is correct, but not
particularly illuminating.
Because the thing that we said
we have some intuition for
is that the pressure
of a gas-- let's
say if I look at it
in terms of beta P,
actually P is the density
times kt, which is 1 over beta,
if you like, or nkT.
It doesn't matter.
And then there will
be corrections.
There will be a term that
is order of n squared.
There will be a term
that is order of n cubed.
And there are
these coefficients,
which are functions
of temperature,
that are called the
virial coefficient.
And this is a virial expansion.
Essentially what
it is is a fitting
of the form of the
pressure of the gas
as a function of density.
In the very low density limit
you get ideal gas result.
And presumably because
of these interactions,
you will get corrections
that presumably also
know about the
potential that went
into the construction of all
of these b bars, et cetera.
So how do we relate these things
that are, say, experimentally
accessible to this expansion
that we have over here?
And the reason it is
not obvious immediately
is because this is an expansion
in chemical potential,
whereas over here,
I have density.
So what do I do?
Well, I realize that the density
can be obtained as follows.
In the grand canonical ensemble,
the number of particles
is in principal a
random variable.
But that random variable
is governed by this e
to the beta mu N that
controls how many you have.
And if I take the log of
Q with respect to beta mu,
I will generate
the average number,
which in the
thermodynamic limit we
expect to be the same thing
as what we thermodynamically
would call the number.
And this log Q we just
established is beta PV.
So what we have here is
the derivative of beta VP
with respect to beta mu.
And if I do this at
constant temperature,
the betas disappear.
This is the same
thing as V dP by d
mu at constant temperature.
But also I can take the
derivative right here.
So what happens?
I will find that the
density which is N over V,
is the derivative of this
expression with respect
to beta mu.
I go and I find that
there's a beta mu.
If I take a derivative of
this with respect to beta mu,
really it's exponential
of beta mu l.
The derivative of it will
give me l e to the beta mu l.
So what I get is a sum
over l e to the beta mu
over lambda cubed.
l gets repeated.
And then I will
have l times this.
So I will have vl bar divided
by l minus 1 factorial.
So the series for
density is very
much like the
series for pressure,
except that you replace 1
over l factorial with 1 over l
minus 1 factorial.
So now my task is clear.
What I should do
is I should solve
given a particular
density for what mu is.
Once I have mu as a
function of density,
I can substitute it back here.
And I will have pressure
as a function of density.
Of course it's clear that
the right variable to look at
is not mu, but x, which is e to
the beta mu over lambda cubed.
This actually has a name.
It's sometimes called fugacity.
So the second
equation is telling me
that the density I can write in
terms of the fugacity as a sum
over l x to the l bl bar divided
by l minus 1 factorial, which
if I were to sort of
write in its full details,
it starts with b1 bar x
plus b2 bar x squared.
Because there I have 0 factorial
or 1 factorial respectively.
The next term will be
b3 bar over 2 x cubed.
And this will go on and on.
Also, let me remind
you what b1 bar is.
b1 bar, for every
one of these b1 bars,
I have to divide by 1
over V because of this V.
And then I have to do the
integration that corresponds
to the one cluster, which is
essentially one cluster going
over the entirety of space,
which will give me V.
So this is in fact 1.
So basically this
coefficient here is 1.
And then I will have
the corrections.
So you say, well, I have
n as a function of x.
I want x as a function of n.
And I say, OK, that's
not that difficult.
I will write that x
equals n minus b2 bar
x squared minus b3 bar x
cubed over 2, and so forth.
And I have now x.
Maybe a few of
you are skeptical.
Some of you don't
seem to be bothered.
OK, so my claim is
that this is indeed
a systematic way of solving
a series in which when
the density goes to 0, you
expect x to also go to 0.
And to lowest order, x will
be of the order of density.
And these will be higher
order powers in density.
So to get a systematic series
in density, all you need to do
is to sort of work with a
series such as this keeping
in mind what order you
have solved things to.
So I claim that to
lowest order, this really
just says that x is n.
And then there are corrections
that are order of n squared.
And to get the next order
term, all I need to do
is to substitute the lower
order in this equation.
So basically if I substitute
x equals n in this equation,
I will get n minus b2 n square.
If I substitute x over n here,
it will be a higher order term.
And I claim that this
is the correct result
to order of n cubed.
And then to get the
result to order of n
cubed, I substitute this back
into the original equation.
So I start with n minus
b2 bar, the square
of the previous solution
at the right order.
So squaring this, I will
get n squared minus twice
b2 bar n cubed.
And the next term that would
be the square of this, which
is order of n to the
fourth, I don't write down.
And then I have
minus b3 bar over 2,
the cube of the
previous solution.
And at the right
order that I have,
that's the same thing
as b3 bar over 2 n cubed
and order of n to the fourth.
And all I really need
to do at this order
is to recognize that
I have two terms that
are order of n cubed.
Putting them together, I have
n minus b2 bar n squared.
And then I have
plus 2b2 bar squared
minus b3 bar over 2 n cubed
and order of n to the fourth.
So now we erase this.
OK, so now I have solved for
x in a power series in n.
All I need to do
is to substitute
in the power series for p.
So let's write that down.
The power series for
beta p is b1 bar times
the density b2 bar
squared over 2 density
square, b3 bar over
3 factorial, which
is 6 n cubed, and so forth.
But I only calculated
things to order of n cubed.
Also, b1 bar is the
same thing as 1.
So basically that's what
I should be working with.
And so all I need to do
is to substitute-- oops,
except that these are all x's.
The series here
for beta p that I
have is in powers
of this quantity x.
And it is x that I had
calculated as a function of n.
To the order that I calculated,
it is n minus b2n squared.
And then I have 2b2
squared minus b3 over b3.
Somehow this sounds
incorrect to me.
Nope, that's fine.
Because here I have 2.
So that's correct.
b3 over 2 n cubed--
so essentially,
I just substituted for x here.
The next order
term is going to be
b2 over 2 times the square of x.
The square of x will give
me a term that is n squared,
a term that is from
here 2b2n cubed.
Order of n to the fourth I
haven't calculated correctly.
Order of n cubed
I have b3 over 6.
And just x cubed is the same
thing as n cubed to this order.
And I have not calculated
anything at the next order.
So let's see what we have.
We have n.
At the next order, there are
two terms that are n squared.
There is this term,
and there is that term.
Putting them together, I will
get minus b2 over 2 n squared.
At the next order, at
the order of n cubed,
I have a bunch of terms.
First of all, there
is this 2b2 squared.
But then multiplying this with
this will subtract one b2.
So I'm going to be
left with b2 squared.
And then I have minus 1/2 b3.
So that's one term.
And then I have plus 1/6 b3.
Minus 1/2 plus 1/6 is minus 1/3.
So this is minus
b3 over 3 n cubed.
And I haven't calculated
order of n to the fourth.
And this is the formula for BP.
So lowest order, I have
the ideal gas result.
Actually, let me,
for simplicity,
define the virial
coefficients in this fashion.
The second order, I will
get a correction B2,
which is minus 1/2 of b2 bar.
So this is minus 1/2
of the diagram that
corresponds to essentially
one of these lines
that I have up here.
And so what is it?
It is minus 1/2 the integral
over the relative coordinate
of e to the minus
beta v as a function
of the relative
coordinate minus 1.
Now earlier, we had in fact
calculated this result directly
through the partition function.
I did a calculation in which
I calculated the first term
in the other way of
looking at things,
in the cumulant expansion,
as a function of expansions
in the potential.
We saw that there
was a term that all
was order of density squared.
We summed all of the
terms to get this factor.
And there was precisely
a factor of minus 1/2
as a correction to
pressure once we
took the derivative of
the partition function
with respect to volume.
OK, so the thing that is new is
really the next order term, B3,
which is b2 squared
minus b3 bar over 3.
OK, so what is that?
Diagrammatically,
B2 was this factor
that we calculated above and
is the square of this pair.
And then I have to subtract
from that 1/3 of whatever
goes into B3.
Now remember, we said that B3,
I have to pick three points
and make sure I link them
in all possible ways.
So the diagrams that go into
B3, one of them is this.
But then there are
three other ways
of making a linked object,
which is these things.
We also saw that if
I were to calculate
the contribution of any
one of these objects,
I can very easily choose
to measure my coordinates
with respect to, say, the
point that is at their apex.
And then I would
have one variable
which is this distance,
one variable which
is that distance.
And independently,
each one of them
would give me the factor
that I calculated before.
In essence, all of these one
particle reducible graphs
give a contribution,
which is the product
of these single line graphs.
There are three of them.
Minus 1/3 precisely
cancels that.
And so the calculation that
goes into the third virial
coefficient ultimately will
only depend on this one graph.
And we had anticipated
this before.
When we were doing
things previously
using the expansion of
the partition function,
we saw that in this
cumulant expansion,
only the cumulants
were appearing.
And for calculation
of the cumulants,
I had to do lots
of subtractions.
And those subtractions
were genetically
removing these one
particle reducible graphs.
And this continues
to all orders.
And the general formula is
that the l-th contribution here
will be a factor of l minus 1
over l factorial, which is not
so difficult to get by
following the procedures
that I have described over here,
and then the part of bl that
is one particle irreducible.
So this is the
eventual result for how
you would be able, given some
particular form of the two body
interaction, to calculate
an expansion for pressure
in powers of density, how the
coefficients of that expansion
are related to properties
of this potential
through this
diagrammatic expansion.
So this is formally correct.
And then the next question
is, is it practical?
Is it useful?
So we need to start computing
things to see something
about the usefulness of this
series for some particular type
of potential.
So we are going to look
at the kind of potential
that I already
described for you.
That is, if I look at two
particles in a gas that
are separated by
an amount r-- let's
imagine the potential
only depends
on the relative distance, not
orientation or anything else.
We said that basically,
at large distances,
the potential is attractive
because of van der Waals.
At short distances, the
potential is repulsive.
And so you have a general
form such as this.
Now, if I want to
do calculations,
it would be useful for
me to have something
that I can do
calculations exactly
with and get an estimate.
So what I'm going to do is
to replace that potential,
essentially, with a hard wall.
So my approximation to the
potential is that my v of r
is infinite for
distances, separations
that are less than some r0.
So basically, I define
some kind of r0,
which is the-- if you think
of them as billiard balls,
it's related to the closest
distance of approach.
This potential at
large distances
has typical van der
Waals form, by which
I mean it falls off as
a function of separation
with the sixth power.
It is attractive.
So I put a minus sign here.
In order to make sure that I
get eventually the dimensions
right, the coefficient that goes
here I write as r0 with a u0
up here such that if I assume
that the potential is precisely
this for all r that are
greater than r0, then
I'm replacing the
actual potential
by something like this.
And the minimum
depth of potential
will occur at this cusp
over here at minus u0.
So why did I do that?
Because now I can
calculate with that
what the second
virial coefficient is.
So what is B2?
B2 is minus 1/2 the integral
of relative potential.
Now this integral
will take two parts
from these two
different contributions.
One part is when I'm in the
regime where the particles are
excluded, the
potential is infinity.
And there, f is simply minus 1.
So that minus 1 then gets
integrated from 0 to r,
giving me the volume
that is excluded.
So what I will get
here is a minus 1
times the excluded volume.
That's the first part, where
the volume is, of course,
4 pi over 3 r0 cubed for
the volume of the sphere.
And then I have to
add the part where
I go from f0 all
the way to infinity.
The potential is
vertically symmetric.
So d cubed r becomes
4 pi r squared dr.
And I have to integrate
e to the minus
beta times the attractive
part of the potential.
So it's beta u0 r0 over
r to the sixth minus 1.
So what I will do,
I will additionally
assume that I'm in the
range of parameters
where this beta u0
is much less than 1,
that is, at temperatures
that are higher
compared to the depth of
this potential converted
to units of kT.
And if that is the case,
then I can expand this.
And the expansion
to the lowest order
will simply give me beta u0
r0 over r to the sixth power.
And I will ignore
higher order terms.
So this, if you like, is
order of beta u0 squared.
Now, having done that, then the
second integral becomes simple.
Because I have to
integrate r squared
divided by r to the fourth,
which is r to the minus 4.
Integral of r to the minus
4 gives me r to the minus 3.
And then there's a factor of
minus 1/3 from the integration.
It has to be evaluated
between 0 and infinity.
And so the final answer,
then, for B2 is minus 1/2.
I have minus 4 pi over 3 r0
cubed from the excluded volume
part.
From here, I will get a 4
pi beta u0 r0 to the sixth.
And then I will get this
factor of r the minus 3
over 3 evaluated
between infinity,
which gives me 0 and r0.
So you can see that with
this potential, actually
both terms are proportional
to 4 pi r0 cubed over 3.
And so I can write the
answer as minus omega over 2
where I have defined omega
to be this 4 pi r0 cubed
over 3, which is
the excluded volume.
Basically, it's the volume that
is excluded from exploration
when you have two particles.
Because their center of mass
cannot come as close as r0.
So that 1/2 appears here as 1.
Because I already
took care of that.
This rest of the coefficients
are proportional to this
except with a factor
of minus beta u0.
So I get minus beta u0.
So this is your second
virial coefficient for this.
AUDIENCE: It should
be positive out front.
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: It should be positive
out front, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes, because
there was a minus,
and there's a minus.
There's a plus.
Let's keep that.
So what we have
so far, we've said
that beta times the pressure
starts with ideal gas behavior
n.
And then I have the
next correction,
which is this B2
multiplying n squared.
So I will have n squared
times this coefficient
that I have calculated for
this type of gas, which
is omega over 2 1 minus beta u0.
And presumably there are
higher order terms in this.
So whenever you see
something like this,
then you have to
start thinking about,
is this a good expansion?
So let's think about
how this expansion could
have become problematic.
Actually, there is already one
thing that I should have noted
and I didn't, which is short
versus long range potential.
Now, it was nice
for this potential
that I got an answer
that was in the form
that I could write
down, factor out omega.
You can say, well,
would you have always
been able to do something
similar to that?
Because you see,
ultimately what this
says is that in order for all
of these terms in this expansion
to be dimensionally correct,
the next term is a density,
has dimensions of
inverse volume,
density squared
compared to this.
So it should be compensated
by some factor of volume.
And we can see that
this factor of volume
came from something
that was of the order
of this size of the
molecule, this r0.
OK, so it's interesting.
It says that it's really
the short-range part
of the potential that seems
to be setting the correction.
Now, where did that come from?
Well, there was one
place that I had
to do an integration
over the potential.
And I found that
the integration was
dominated by the lower range.
That was over here.
Where would this
become difficult?
AUDIENCE: In a small box?
PROFESSOR: In a
small box, but we
are always taking the
thermodynamic limit
where V goes to infinity.
AUDIENCE: Or inverse square log?
PROFESSOR: Inverse square
log, yes, that's right.
So who says that this
integral should converge?
I'm doing an integral d cubed
r, something like v of r.
And convergence was the
reason why this integral
was dominated by short distance.
If this potential goes
like 1 over r cubed,
then it will logarithmically
depend on the size of the box.
For Coulomb interaction,
1/r potential
you can't even think about it.
It's just too divergent.
So this expansion will
fail for potentials
that have tails that
are decaying as 1
over r cubed or even slower.
Fortunately, that's not
the case for van der Waals'
potential and
typical potentials.
But if you have a plasma,
you have to worry about this.
And that's why I was
also saying last time
that the typical expansions
that you have to do for plasmas
are different.
So given that we are
dominated by the short range,
what is the correction
that I've obtained
compared to the first term?
So essentially, I have
calculated a second order term
that is of the order of this
divided by the first order
term and pressure
that was density.
And we find that this is
of the order of n omega.
How many particles are within
the range of interaction?
And this would be
kind of like the ratio
of the density of liquid
to the density of gas.
Because the density of
liquid would be related-- oh,
it's the other way around.
The density of liquid
would be 1 over the volume
that one particle occupies.
So the density of liquid
would go in the denominator.
The density of gas is this
n that I have over here.
And again, for the
gas in this room,
this ratio is of the order
of 10 to the minus 3.
And we are safe.
But if I were to
start compressing this
so that I go to higher
and higher densities,
ultimately I say that this
second order term becomes
of the order of the
first order term.
And then perturbation
doesn't make sense.
Naturally, the reason for
that is I haven't calculated.
But typically what you
find is that if you
go to higher and
higher order terms
in the series, in most cases,
but clearly not in all cases,
the ratio of successive
terms is more or less
set by the ratio
of the first terms.
It has to be
dimensionally correct.
And we've established that
the typical dimension that
is controlling everything is
the volume of the particle.
So this expansion will fail
for long range potentials,
for going to
liquid-like densities.
But also I made
another thing, which
is that I assumed that that
could expand this exponential.
And then in principle,
there are other difficulties
that could arise if this
condition that I wrote here
is violated.
If beta u0 is greater than 1,
then this coefficient by itself
becomes large exponentially.
And then you would expect that
higher order terms will also
get more factors of this
exponential and potential.
And things will blow up on you.
So it will also
have difficulties
at low temperatures for
attractive potentials.
Again, the reason
for that is obvious.
If you have an
attractive potential,
you go to low
enough temperature,
and the ground state is
everybody sticking together--
looks nothing like a gas, looks
like a solid or something.
So these are the
kind of limitations
that one has in this series.
OK, let's be brave
and do some more
rearrangements of this equation.
So I have that to
this order, beta P
is n plus n squared
this excluded
volume over 2 1 minus beta u0.
And then there's higher
order terms of course.
And then I notice that there are
two terms on this equation that
are proportional to beta.
And I say, why not put
both of them together?
So I will have beta.
Bring that term to
this side, and it
becomes P plus n
squared omega over 2 u0.
And then what is left
on the other side?
Let's factor out the n.
I expect this to be a series in
higher and higher powers of n.
And the first
correction to 1 comes
from here, which
is n omega over 2.
And I expect there to
be higher order terms.
Now again, to order of n squared
that I have calculated things
correctly, this
expression is no different
from the following expression--
1 minus n omega over 2.
Again, there will be
higher order terms in n.
But the order of n squared,
both of these equations,
expressions, are equivalent.
So if I now ignore
higher order terms,
this whole thing is equivalent
to P plus n squared u--
well, let's write this in
the following fashion-- p
plus u0 omega over 2 N over
V, which is density squared.
And actually this side, if
I were to multiply by V,
what do I get?
This becomes numerator
V, denominator V minus N
omega over 2.
Let's multiply by V
minus N omega over 2.
And the right-hand
side will be--
AUDIENCE: Is that where
it should be there?
PROFESSOR: What happened?
AUDIENCE: This one, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, so if I multiply
this, which is N over V, by V,
I will get N,
good, which removes
the difficulty that I had.
Because now I multiply by kT.
And the left hand
side disappears.
And on the right hand
side, I will get NkT.
So we'll spend some
time on this equation
that you will likely recognize
as the van der Waals equation.
I kind of justify it by
rearranging this series.
But van der Waals
himself, of course,
had a different way
of justifying it,
which is that basically if
we think about the ideal gas,
and you have particles that are
moving within some volume V,
if you have excluded
volume interactions,
then some of this volume
is no longer available.
And so maybe what
you should do is
you should reduce the
volume by an amount that
is proportional to the
number of particles.
This factor of 1/2 is
actually very interesting.
Because it is correct.
And I see that a
number of people
in well known
journals, et cetera,
write that the excluded
volume should be essentially
n times the volume that is
excluded around each particle.
It's not that.
It is 1/2 of that.
And I'll leave you
to mull on that.
Because we will
justify it later on.
But in the meantime,
you can think
about why the factor
of 1/2 is there.
The other issue
is that-- so there
has to be a correction
to the volume.
And the kind of
hand-waving statement
that you make about the
correction to pressure
is that if you think about the
particle that is in the middle,
it is being attracted by
everybody, whereas when
it comes to the surface, it
is really being attracted
by things that are
half of the space.
So there is an
effective potential
that the particles feel
from the collective action
of all the others, which
is slightly less steep when
you approach the boundaries.
And therefore, you can either
think that because of this,
there's less density that
you have at the boundary.
Less density will give
you less pressure.
Or if you have a
particle that is
kind of moving
towards the wall, it
is being pulled
back so it doesn't
hit the wall as strongly
as you would expect,
that would give the
pressure of the ideal gas.
So there is a pressure that
has to be reduced related
to the strength of the
potential and something that
has to do with all of
the other particles.
And there's density
squared will appear there.
We will have a more full
justification of this equation
later on.
But for the time being, let's
sort of sit with this equation
and think about its
consequences for awhile.
Because the thing that
we would like to do
is we have come from a
perspective of looking
at the ideal gas and how the
pressure of the ideal gas
starts to get corrected
because of the interactions.
Of course, things
become interesting
when you go to the dense limit.
And then the gas becomes
something like a liquid.
And you have transitions
and things like that.
So really, it's the other limit,
the dense, highly interacting
limited that is interesting.
And to get that, we
have few choices.
Either I have to somehow sum
many, many terms in the series,
which will be very difficult,
and we can't do that,
or you can make some kind of
approximation, rearrangement,
and a guess.
And this is what the van der
Waals equation is based on.
I made the guess here
by somewhat rearranging
and re-summing the
terms in this series.
But I will give you shortly
a different justification
that is more transparent
and tells you immediately
what the limitations are.
But basically that's
why we are going
to spend some time
with this equation.
Because ultimately, we
are hoping to transition
from the weakly interacting
case to the strongly interacting
case.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, no,
no, no, omega was
defined as the volume
excluded around one particle.
So if you're thinking
about billiard balls,
r0 is the diameter.
It's not the radius.
And 4 pi over 3 r0 cubed
is 8 times the diameter
of a single billiard ball.
So the correction that
we get, if you like,
is 4 times the volume of
a billiard ball multiplied
by the number of billiard balls.
Where was I?
OK, so what this equation
gives you, the van der Waals,
is an expression for
how the pressure behaves
as a function of volume.
Actually, it would be nicer
if we were to sort of replace
this by volume per
particle, which
would be the inverse density.
But you can use
one or the other.
It doesn't matter.
Now, what you find is
that there is, first
of all, a limitation
to the volume.
So basically, none
of your cares are
going to go to volumes that
are lower than n omega over 2.
So basically there's a barrier
here that occurs over here.
But if you go to
the other limit,
where you go to large volumes,
you can ignore terms like this.
And then you get back the
kind of ideal gas behavior.
So basically, in
one limit, where
you are either at
high temperatures--
and at high temperatures,
essentially, the correction
here will also be negligible.
Or you are at high
values of the volume.
You get isotherms that are
very much like the isotherms
that you have for the
ideal gas, except that
rather than asymptote
to 0, PV going like NkT,
you asymptote to
this excluded volume.
So this is for high T, T large.
T larger than what?
Well essentially,
what happens is
that if I look at the pressure,
I can write it in this fashion
also.
It is NkT divided by V
minus N omega over 2.
So that's the term that
dominates at high temperature.
It's proportional to kT.
But then there's the subtraction
u0 omega over 2 N/V squared.
And again, this term is not
so important at large volume.
Because at large
volume, this 1/V
is more dominant than
1 over V squared.
But as you go to
lower temperatures
and intermediate volumes,
then essentially you
have potentially a correction
that falls off as minus 1
over V squared.
And so this correction that
falls off as 1 over V squared
can potentially
modify your curve,
bring it down, and then give
it a structure such as this.
So this is T less than.
And clearly, between these
two types of behavior,
where there is
monotonic behavior
or non-monotonic
behavior, there has
to be a limiting curve that,
let's say, does something
like this, comes tangentially
to the horizontal axis,
and then goes on like this.
So this would be
for T equals Tc.
This is T greater than
Tc, T less than Tc.
OK, so that's fine,
except that now we
have encountered the difficulty.
Because one of the things
that we had established
for thermodynamic stability
was that delta P delta
V had to be negative.
And the ideal gas
curve and portions
of this curve which
have a negative slope
are all consistent with this.
But this portion over here
where dP by dV is positive,
it kind of violates
the condition
that the compressibility
kappa T, which is minus 1/V dV
by dP at constant temperature,
better be positive.
And so clearly, the expression
that one gets through this van
der Waals equation
has a limitation.
And the most
natural way about it
is to say, well, the
question that you wrote down
is clearly incorrect.
That's certainly true.
Also, this equation
is incorrect,
except that this
kind of reminds us
with what actually happens if I
look at the isotherms of a gas,
such as gas in this
room, or something that
is more familiar, such as water.
What you find is that
at high temperatures,
you indeed have curves
that look like this.
But at low temperatures,
you liquidify.
And what you have is
a zone of coexistence,
let's say something
like this, by which I
mean that the
isotherm that you draw
has a portion that
lives in the gas phase
and is a slightly modified
version of the ideal gas.
But then it has a
portion that corresponds
to the more or less
incompressible liquid.
Although this has clearly still
some finite compressibility.
And then in between, there is a
region where if you have a box,
part of your box would be
liquid, and part of your box
would be gas.
And as you compress the box,
the proportion of liquid and gas
will change.
And this happens for
T less than some Tc.
And once more, there
is a curve that kind of
looks like this at some
intermediate temperature Tc.
So you look at the
comparison, you say, well,
as long as I stay
above Tc-- of course
I don't expect this equation
to give the right numbers
for what Tc or whatever is.
But qualitatively, I get
topologies and behaviors
at that T greater
than Tc all the way up
to Tc are not very different.
But at T less than
Tc, they also signal
that something bad is happening.
And somehow, the original
description has to be modified.
And so the thing that Maxwell
and van der Waals and company
did was to somehow convert
this incorrect set of equations
to something that
resembles this.
So let's see how they
managed to do this.
Actually, this may not be a
bad thing to keep in mind.
Let's have a
thermodynamic-- well,
I kind of emphasize that there
is thermodynamic reason for why
this is not valid.
Always there's a
corresponding reason
if you look at things
from the perspective
of statistical mechanics.
So it may be useful
to sort of think
about what's happening
from that perspective.
Let's imagine that we are in
this grand canonical ensemble.
In the grand canonical ensemble,
the number of particles,
as we discussed, is not fixed.
But the mean number of particles
is given by the expressions
that we saw over
here, is related
to the pressure through dP by
d mu at constant temperature.
But there are fluctuations.
So you would say that the
fluctuations are related
by taking a second
derivative of this object.
Because clearly, q, if I were to
expand it in powers of beta mu,
will generate
various moments of n.
Log of q will
generate cumulants.
So the variance would
be one more derivative.
And so that will
amount to taking
a derivative of the
first derivative, which
was the number itself.
So I will get this to be
dN by d mu at constant T,
except that there's an
additional factor of kT.
So maybe I will write
this carefully enough.
I have d2 log Q with
respect to beta mu squared
will give me N squared.
Now, the first derivative with
respect to beta mu of log Q
gave me the mean, which I'm
actually thinking of as N
itself.
And then there's
this factor of beta.
So this is really kT dN by d mu.
All of these are done
at constant temperature.
So the statistical
analog of stability
really comes down to
variances being positive.
So my claim is that this
variance being positive
is related to this
stability condition.
Let me do that in the
following fashion.
I divide these two expressions.
I will get the average
of N squared divided
by average of N, which is really
N, so the variance over N.
I have kT.
And then I have the ratio
of two of these derivatives.
And the reason I
wanted to do that ratio
was to get rid of the d mu.
Because d mu is not so nice.
If I take the ratio of
those two derivatives,
I will get dN by
dP at constant T.
But what I really wanted was
to say something about dV
by dP at constant T
rather than dN by dP.
So what I'm going to do is to
somehow convert this dN by dP
into dN by dV,
and then dV by dP.
And actually to do that, I
need to use the chain rule.
So this will be T,
P. This will be T, N.
And the chain rule will give
me an additional minus sign.
So this is a reminder of
how your partial derivatives
and the chain rule goes.
Finally, dN by dV is none
other than the density N/V.
At constant temperature, N
and V will be proportional.
And what I have here
is 1/V dV by dP,
which is the compressibility.
So the whole thing here
is NkT times kappa of T.
And so this being positive,
this positivity of the variance,
is-- the thermodynamic
analog of it
was from the stability,
and something such as this.
The statistical analog of
it is that the probability
distribution that I'm looking at
in the grand canonical ensemble
as a function of N has to be
peaked around some region.
The variance around
that peak better
be positive so that I'm looking
in the vicinity of a maximum.
If it was negative,
it means that I'm
looking in the
vicinity of a minimum.
And I'm looking at the
least likely configuration.
So it cannot be allowed.
So that's the
statistical reason.
OK, now I want to use
that in connection
with what we have
over here and see
what I can learn about this.
I said that I wrote two
expressions and divided them,
because I didn't want to deal
with the chemical potential.
But let me redefine that
and say the following,
that N is V dP by
d mu at constant T.
And maybe I will start to
gain some idea about chemical
potential if I
rearrange this as d mu
is V/N dP along this surface
of constant P at constant T.
And then I can calculate
mu as a function of P
at some particular
temperature minus mu
at some reference point by
integrating from the reference
point to the
pressure of interest
the quantity V/N dP prime
where V of P prime I
take from this curve.
So this curve gives me
P as a function of V.
But I can invert it and think
of V as a function of P,
put it here, and see what is
happening with the chemical
potential if I walk along
one of these trajectories.
And in particular, let's
kind of draw one of these
curves that I am
unhappy with that
have this kind of
form in general
and calculate what happens
to the chemical potential
if I, let's say, pick
this reference point
A, and the corresponding
pressure PA,
and go along this curve, which
corresponds to some temperature
T that is less than this
instability temperature,
and track the shape of
the chemical potential.
So this formula says that the
change in chemical potential we
obtained by calculating
V-- divide by N,
but our N is fixed--
as a function of P,
and integrating as
you go up in pressure.
So essentially, I'm calculating
the integral starting
from point A as I
go under this curve.
So let's plot as a result
of that integration how
that chemical potential at
P minus PA is going to look
like as I go in P beyond PA.
So at PA, that's my reference.
The chemical potential
is some value.
As I go up and up, because
of this area of this curve,
I keep adding to the
chemical potential
until I reach the maximum
here at this point C.
So there is some curve that goes
from this A to some point C.
Now, the thing is that when I
continue going along this curve
down this potential all the way
to the bottom of this, which
I will call D, my
DP's are negative.
So I start subtracting
from what I had before.
And so then the curve
starts to go down.
So all the way to
D, I'm proceeding
in the opposite direction.
Once I hit D, I start going all
the way to the end of the curve
however far I want to go.
And I'm adding
some positive area.
So the next part I also have a
variation in chemical potential
that goes like this.
So you ask, well, if I give
you what the temperature is
and what the pressure
is-- and I have told you
what the temperature
and pressure are--
I should be able to calculate
the chemical potential.
It's an intensive
function of the other two
intensive functions.
And this curve tells me
that, except that there
are regions where I don't
know which one to pick.
There are regions where
it's obvious there's
one value of the
chemical potential.
But there is in between,
because of this instability,
three possible values.
And typically, if
you have systems--
think about different chemicals
that can go between each other.
And there are potentials for
chemical transformations.
You say, go and pick the
lowest chemical potential.
The system will evolve
onto the condition that
has the lowest
chemical potential.
So that says that when you
have a situation such as this,
you really have to
pick the lowest one.
And so you have to bail out on
your first curve at the point
B, and on your second curve at
a point E, where on this curve
B and E are such that when
you integrate this BDP all
the way from B to E, you will
get 0, which means that you
have to find points B and E
such that the integral here
is the same as
the integral here.
And this is the so-called
Maxwell construction.
So what that means is that
originally I was telling you
over here that there is some
portion of the curve that
violates all kinds
of thermodynamics.
And you should not access it.
And this other argument that
we are pursuing here says that
actually the regions that you
cannot access are beyond that.
There's a portion that
extends in this direction,
and a portion that
extends in that direction.
And really there's a portion
that you can access up to here,
and a portion that you
can access up to here.
And maybe you
should sort of then
join them by a straight
line and make an analog
with what we have over there.
Now, in another thing,
another way of looking at this
is that the green portion
is certainly unstable,
violates all kinds of
thermodynamic conditions.
And people argue that
these other portions that
have the right slope are
in some sense metastable.
So this would be a
stable equilibrium.
This would be an
unstable equilibrium.
And a metastable equilibrium
is that you are at a minimum,
but there's a deeper
minimum somewhere else.
And the picture is that if
you manage to take your gas
and put additional
pressure on it,
there is a region where there
is a coexistence with the liquid
which is better in terms
of free energy, et cetera.
But there could be some
kind of a kinetic barrier,
like nucleation or whatever,
that prevents you to go there.
And this again is something
that is experimentally observed.
If you try to rapidly
pressurize a gas,
you could sometimes avoid
and not make your transition
to the liquid state
at the right pressure.
But if you were to do
things sufficiently slowly,
you would ultimately
reach this point
that corresponds to
the true equilibrium
pressure of making
this transition.
Now, the thing is that
somehow this whole story
is not very satisfactory.
I started with
some rearrangement
of some perturbative to
arrive at this equation.
This equation has
this unstable portion.
And somehow I'm trying to relate
something that makes absolutely
no thermodynamic
sense and try to gain
from it some idea about what is
happening in a real liquid gas
system.
So it would be
good if all of this
could be more formally
described within a framework
where all of the approximations,
et cetera, are clear,
and we know what's going on.
And so next time,
we will do that.
We will essentially developed a
much more systematic formalism
for calculating the properties
of an interacting gas,
and see that we get this, and
we also understand why it fails.